good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast hope everyone is
having a splendiferous Tuesday out here
in New York it's very gloomy very sad
but we are really excited because we
have our first guest in our new studio
today we are joined by the queen of
Vanderpump rules Kristin Doty a very hot
topic of conversation last week so I'm
really glad to have her here just to get
a little bit heated up like I definitely
have some questions for her I look
forward to fighting about her in front
of her and I feel as though there's more
to the story I want to know where her in
Carter's stand right now and that'll
help me make my decisions going forward
also there's a lot going on like in
banner pump rules life and now because
Lala Britney Katie and Stassi like are
all in this girl's trip to Park City
scheana and Ariana are tweeting about
the fact that they weren't invited and I
just want to know like was Kristen
invited or like maybe she was invited
but she's busy she's not much up inside
this week I think like maybe maybe she's
like a prestigious morning show to go on
but like sometimes there's a girls trip
and not everyone's invited and it
doesn't mean you're not friends but like
you just weren't invited knows not
everything can be like a 10 person trip
I completely great just because you're
friends with someone doesn't mean like
you do everything together yet it
definitely implies weirdness like that
there's a certain core group of people
going I bet I feel as though we all knew
there was a core group and then there's
the extended group i if it weren't like
I always assumed Kristen was a part of
the core group which is a we go as if
not for this episode and also you have
to keep in mind this episode was filmed
like almost a year ago no but like
things are weird she wasn't at the
engagement party yeah a writers drama
that's wet and maybe like their fault I
now but maybe she got demoted from core
yeah but I need to see scheana not
understanding why she's not core it's
like if I'm understanding why aren't you
understanding yeah
Ariana understanding why she's not quite
it's like there's there's she's gotten
taken down with scheana
yeah there's weirdness but there's not
bad blood with Ariana it's just like
she's kind of different than all the
other girls Sheena like there's visible
like blood it's just like sometimes the
whole group's not invited and it's okay
we're 35 years old I agree okay but it's
like we're on a reality show like it's
not okay but we're not filming so it's
okay yeah
okay so we have Kristen Doherty we have
obviously top 5 stories so much going on
you guys I was just singing about it in
2020 is already so wild like even if
nothing else happens this year like the
biggest news of all time happen which is
exit um and now just everyday things are
popping up it's like 20 to 20 20 knew we
were gonna be in the studio and like we
needed to put on good shows and I go
she is not disappointing she's not dis
important and like it more than news -
there's more Mexican ooze because the
Queen released a statement after what
seemed to be like a very short
conference call via dial in which
apparently Megan like I guess she didn't
get the pin number no they said that she
didn't need to be there no but I
sometimes I've said that one I haven't
known the pin number and I'm just like
too scared to ask
yeah but also like think of it just
their Royals but they're also just a
couple in-laws so like you're having
problems with your in-laws who would
obviously send your husband like you
gonna need to go to the meeting like it
makes sense yeah but like her calling in
so she can hear what they're saying
about her and so that everyone sort of
has to be measured I understood that but
I guess maybe they couldn't set up the
dial-in because sometimes that's really
hard like they should have gone to
freeconferencecall.com such a good
service maybe they don't have that in
the UK mmm you know I actually do you
think it's an American I mean it's free
conference called that UK over there and
they got it wrong they went calm cuz
she's used to living in the stay and she
was like you'll just fill me and send me
the bullet points because their private
secretaries they're so like I'm sure she
got the news it makes sense well we got
the notes because then the Queen
releases semen which we will get to yes
much to talk about today because the
bachelor was on last night Lots
unwrapped we're keeping up so far so
much to unwrap like I really felt as
though the episode revolved around the
world I took notes and I worked on
people's names cuz [ __ ] it is so hard
like those first five episodes like
there's so many people who are
irrelevant in the grand scheme of like
the storyline with Peter but you like
discuss them in terms of like the girl
drama and it's just not worth knowing
their names but sitting her being like
the girl the black dress is so annoying
no but it's it's also funny
yeah like I was laughing thinking about
how last week when we were recapping we
were talking on and we said her name
differently she had every single time
it's not she named Shane I don't know
Shanny
there's no not chatting it's it's she
wasn't really in this episode to be
never getting married so we never got
clarity but we'll recap at the end right
before Kristen yeah but I think we
should just get right to it because
there's so much to talk about and I have
so many thoughts on so many things like
she'd potentially being a juror for
Harvey Weinstein's like 2020 like calm
down it's just January relax it's just
it's so crazy so I think so what are you
saying I
I'm saying I'm gonna go off-book for a
second I'm gonna say that it's time even
though it's only been four minutes wow
that's crazy yeah I know that's how much
we just have to get into and I'm just so
sick of beating around the bush circling
the drain yeah so it's it's time for the
past five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
but you know much like my good friend
ratatouille once said i would be
remissed devastated and heartbroken i
would have a case of RDH if I didn't let
everyone know that today's episode is
brought to you by Squarespace they've
got everything you need to make your
business a piece of cake
they've got domains websites online
stores and marketing tools from websites
and online stores to marketing tools and
analytics Squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business you say
more you sell more stand out in any
inbox with Squarespace email campaigns
their all-in-one platform makes it easy
to unify your brand from a voice from
your homepage to your emails you have
consistent concept content from your
website to your email powerful editing
tools to make make it your own
customized layouts for any message and
mobile editing so you can send anytime
anywhere
Jackie and I use Squarespace to get our
camp trust website together which is
coming soon and it's just easy I think
sometimes starting a website is super
daunting and things like Squarespace
just make it so easy they've got domains
you can just get you know Claudia is the
best the baddest [ __ ] at the game.com
they'll help you secure the domain
secure the bag
it's really it's great if you want to
start a blog maybe like mechana from The
Bachelor they can help you blog and
publish content make it super premium
and we just think that's something every
toaster needs if you're a small toaster
running a small business so here we go
we got something for you guys go to
squarespace.com slash toast for a free
trial and then when you're ready to
launch you can use the offer code toast
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain so go to
squarespace.com slash toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's squarespace.com
slash test sign on get a website you
know it's 20/20
let's see what does he do him okay first
story queen has released a statement
regarding Meg's it and she may have
dropped a hint about harry and megan
losing their titles so queen elizabeth
ii failed to refer to prince harry and
Megan Marco as the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex in a statement Monday raising
doubts about whether the Royal pair will
keep their titles
this is like true Easter egg hunting no
it's actually pretty blatant you know
like it's not a trailer Swift seven palm
tree situation which by the way what did
it ever mean nothing she was just
posting a picture of some trees I think
that's what I said that it had meant
yeah the palace had tweeted out a
statement from the Queen after an
emergency summit over Meg sit the
renegade royal couples plan to drop
their senior duties while living at
least part of the time in North America
duties in her missive in which the quote
entirely supportive Queen says she would
still would have preferred a different
path for the pair
she only refers to the prince and his
American wife as Harry and Megan or the
Sussex is that is a noteworthy departure
from previous statements in which she
referred to them by their full royal
titles British media said what is most
remarkable about this statement perhaps
is the Queen referring to them as Harry
and Megan and not by their royal titles
could be a big clue for the future
tweeted The Daily Mirror's Rory leddit
er Russell Meyer's so the Sussex is does
that mean her last name is now Sussex
that's weird that like their titles
would be referred to as their last names
you know no I don't think it's their
last that's their last name now but they
are the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
therefore the Sussex is you know it just
seems like a very roundabout way of
calling them like something you know no
but I feel like it it like our will in
case the point is for in yes because
otherwise they're the Windsors which is
their last name which is everyone emily
is to others and Megan like I don't
think her last name is Windsor now no I
don't I don't think it is either change
her name did Kate I don't think that's a
thing yeah because you're you lose your
last name forever like yeah just the
Royal and you barely even have it like
the Royals barely have a last name and
it's just like a chosen name and it
doesn't really mean that you can be like
a big fan of the Royals and not even
know their last name yeah it's Windsor
by the way it is Windsor it was changed
after World War Two because it used to
be like a cuz she married Mountbatten
and that's like Germany vibes and they
were I got it
so it really is pretty arbitrary anyways
I do think this is interest on um my
stance on Meg sit as of Tuesday January
whatever it is is that whatever the
Queen says I that is how I feel so I
feel as though the Queen is being very
supportive she doesn't want to start
trouble so I'm not going to start
further trouble
ever she is being a little shad a better
in wha right not using their titles
therefore I can be a little shot David
or anyone yeah honestly I feel like in
every statement that they released they
always make sure to note the financial
independence of it all which I feel like
it's kind of smart because this whole
thing is like so crazy and traumatic but
if they were like living the life in
Toronto on to the public funds like that
would be even worse so at the end of the
day they're not doing anything illegal
whatever you think about it it's like
whether they're being shady or thirsty
whatever they're not doing anything like
wrong now unethical you know no they're
just being highly disrespectful to one
of the oldest institutions of all time
but I mean what's that when like you can
have a Netflix deal I totally agree
again also it's like people are like I
don't know if people are feeling as
though it's so you know selfless of them
to not take my taxpayer money but it's
like taxpayer money is nothing compared
to what they're about to make you know
nobody's on the dollar one can tell them
how to spend it like right when you are
being paid by the taxpayers like
everyone's rural skiing at what you're
spending and everything has to be in
line but like why would you even want
taxpayer money when if you renounce it
and you can make even more money right
and it's freely yeah yeah um I don't
think they're doing anyone any favors by
not taking right right it's just it's an
ethics thing like they can't like live a
free life on the British time and I
think they're happy to get off the dime
piece looking forward to it yeah now
like because now they're hopping on to
quarters oh yeah now they're making a
half dollar dollar bills yeah I mean
this is just such a crazy story again I
don't know when we'll stop talking about
it but um I just need to fast forward
six months and like see what their life
is like so they and they I think they
pretty much confirm they're gonna live
in Toronto did they I I haven't seen
anything of the sort oh I I've seen she
has nothing of the sort
nothing um it will be interesting where
we are in six months and that I think
will show what their intentions were
here right um I do I hope that they get
that quiet life that they're looking for
you know sure you know sure Jim I do
like if that's really what they want is
peace oh hi Archie to grow up normally
then I think that everyone like we need
to respect that gene she's gonna write a
book what's like in the history of books
the biggest advance anyone's ever gotten
I remember when Amy Schumer got eight
million
like a huge deal I have no idea when or
what Michelle Obama got like probably
like 30 more than a yummy Schumer I feel
like Megan Marco will get the same
amount but I think if they're gonna the
royal family is now putting forth this
vibe that all's good and we support them
and there's no rift and they're trying
to quell the rift
therefore megan can't go out and write
the tell-all like she can't break that
no the book wouldn't be a tell-all it
would just be like like a memoir
yeah it should be like a how-to guide
like how to be a princess know how to go
from being in hallmark movies to being a
royal yeah and then leave right I would
be very interested in how to guide I
would - yeah like she's one of those
girls like you know just become a
princess overnight you know you have to
be you have to want it you know and it's
like Kate Middleton was kind of born
into it so she wanted it and she got
there but she didn't work hard for it
you know like Megan Marco worked hard
for it oh I think they both worked hard
for it
same but I think it was way easier like
Kate Kate's mom put her in school with
the Kayden William broke up for a time
yeah but like she didn't have to for her
to find her way into British society
wasn't that difficult she's British and
she was like in the upper class of of
London like and she went to st. Andrews
like she was in the right time right
place like Megan Markel was in you know
some casting couch in Hollywood five
years ago I think Kate Middleton I think
they both worked hard for it you don't
just become a princess overnight but
Kate Middleton's whole life revolved
around her becoming a princess like from
the time she was born it was like
incumbent on her to like make these
connections I wasn't friends so her
whole life has been working for this
whereas I think Megan the idea came to
her later on of course but it was much
it was a much further jump she had to
cross I got it she made it look so easy
totally just like walking out with her
thin ankles and that white coat who
could ever forget good times yeah so
that you could have style - imagine if
you had told us then what would happen
now right it's like she's a princess and
then it's like no she doesn't want to be
one anymore no she is like I know I keep
saying this and it's like so annoying
but like I just want to know what's
going on like we can sit here and you
know guess but we'll never really know
what was happening on the conference
call and I just really want to know
but the Queen putting out a statement is
as close to nobody Oh Queen the horse's
mouth is where we're gonna get it from I
think the queen is at the end of the day
really going to put
what she wants people to know everything
but I only wanted people to know that
like she is is pissed we would know it
yeah but she could be pissed and we not
know because she doesn't want us to know
but the Queen doesn't get like super
emotional and heated but she's very
rational and whatever is the best
decision for the longevity of the Royals
is the decision that she's gonna make
and so that's that's the camp fom him
yeah I don't really have like a stake in
the game because like I don't really
care about like I'm not British I'm just
really looking at it from like a gossip
standpoint like the tea is hot you know
he is so happening it's exciting for you
from your gossip standpoint that like
now Megan and Harry are going to be
celebrity at the Met Gala yeah and
they'll be at these events and they'll
be spoken about like celebrities whereas
when you're a royal it's just a
different ear yeah but I think the way
that they're going it's like they're I
don't know that they'll ever be above
the royal family but more ubiquitous no
they'll probably be the most famous
people in America they miss people on
earth yeah that's so crazy mm-hmm it's a
little homework star yeah I'm just
saying the power of hallmark just can't
be underestimated and you guys wonder
why that's my dream it's you want to be
princess a princess so dream big so when
I'm saying like all I want is just a
small role on hallmark what we know is I
want to be a member of the royal family
and then I want to have the option to
renounce it's good to have attainable
goals it is what it is it is it's all
about resolutions you know totally
that's 2020 okay let's get to our next
story because it's some of the craziest
news I've ever heard but I mean in
today's day and age it's just another
day you know because Gigi Hadid has been
called as a potential juror for Harvey
Weinstein's trial how does something
like this happen like of all the New
Yorkers in all the world you had to walk
into my courtroom mm-hmm in a collision
of celebrity tabloid stars and criminal
justice that could only happen in the
Big Apple supermodel Gigi Hadid strolled
into a Manhattan courtroom Monday to be
considered as a juror in the sex assault
case of fallen film mogul Harvey
Weinstein the famous cat Walker wearing
an oversized men's blazer over a white
shirt sauntered into the jury pool with
119 other prospect prospective citizens
on of Manhattan on the fifth day of jury
selection the just the Justice asked her
and
other potential jurors does anyone
believe you know me the defendant or any
one of the lawyers which is a question
they always ask jurors and she raised
her hand after the judge called on her
she stood up in the jury box identified
herself as Jelena Hadid her real first
name
she said that's her name she said I have
met the defendant with Weinstein looking
on from the defense table the judge
asked a supermodel do you think you can
be a fair and impartial juror in this
case yes she said then the judge read a
list of more than 80 names of potential
witnesses and people who may be
referenced during testimony including
actresses Salma Hayek Charlize Theron
and Rosie Perez and Ryan Beattie he
asked the prospective panelist whether
anyone knows them she raised her hand
again she said I have met Salma Hayek
and patan possibly Ryan beating she said
I think I'm still able to keep an open
mind on the facts so she is still in the
process for selection so I obviously get
like why from an image standpoint like
she should want to be a juror like to
seek justice like she's a feminist but
at the end of the day like I feel like
she definitely should not be a juror for
many reasons like one I just not that I
think Harvey Weinstein is innocent by
any means but he has the right to a fair
trial and she is involved like in some
way or the other
and I feel like if she does get on the
jury like that's just like one way get
like Harvey Weinstein could be like I'm
a mistrial yeah like I thought gets
unfair there was a supermodel like what
are we gonna give him that opportunity
he could argue the cheese friends with
Salma Hayek right but I obviously
understand why that she would not back
down because and also it is her civil
duty she's answering the questions like
she feels as though she can be a fair
juror and you know everyone tries to get
out of jury duty but you have to answer
those questions fairly but there's a
hundred and twenty other candidates
right now I don't think she'll be chosen
because I do think she's too close to it
right and there 119 other people that it
is so hard to find jurors apparently two
people have already been like housing
contempt because they were like tweeting
about how excited they were to be on
this panel
oh when someone said like tweeted that
he was eager to secure a seat on the
jury to promote his novel how sighing oh
my god it'd be impossible no impossible
it's gonna be like oj I remember they
had to keep them all in
like sequestered requestor in a hotel no
phone no TV they were like going crazy
that's what it's gonna be that's show
nuts yeah I mean I wouldn't want to be
on the jury
like I just I think like it's be fun for
a while like being a part of this like
whole thing but like so boring so boring
but it would be exciting it would be
great for your career honestly that's
why they wouldn't let me
I know anyone who could personally
benefit from this career-wise it's not
gonna be yeah I bet you this is really
like oj member they all wrote books this
is actually the only trial I could sit
on if I'm a New York Justice Department
because I couldn't wind up doing the
jury the sit on the jury that I was in
the process for because the trial was
gonna be too long and I had to go to
work but if my juris rightness became
part of my work to a jury duty yeah
became my duty then I could take a duty
I love that for you totally I mean this
is just I feel like celebrities
definitely have a way of getting out of
jury do you do like I don't really hear
about celebrities in jury duty that much
so I kind of feel like just could have
been avoided no but I think jury duty
it's like death and taxes like it's part
of being a civil servant and you have to
show up and you can get out of it you
can say oh I have a shoot I'm ready here
I'm gonna be out of town for you I can
show on this but you have to show up and
that's what she was doing yesterday
well you're something crazy before I was
before he was president my friend Jenna
was and jury duty with Trump that's like
a man about town in New York he
obviously got out of it immediately but
he sat there like for a while and spoke
to everyone that is so crazy Jerry duty
like was never that exciting for me and
they'll tell me who summoned for jury
duty all the time like I don't know they
just can't get enough of me I'm I'm
personally insulted that I wasn't called
down on this day um I just been
personally insulted that I was called
the opportunity when I was 18 um and in
order to be eligible for jury duty all
you have to do is be registered to vote
and I was not registered to vote and I
just feel like I serve jury duty like
one extra time in my life because I
shouldn't have been served
interesting I mean it sounds like a you
a you issue you know anything like that
was it was illegal honestly and I want I
want my registered for something that
put you into jury selection I'm telling
you at him maybe it was getting your
driver's license I'm telling you I'm
telling you that you did because like
the government's a system coming after
me again and again
no the the system like the system
doesn't see the system's broke the
system is broken I think that the jury
system is as good as it's gonna get yeah
I mean I have a theory that there should
be a professional jury like yes but then
inherently that goes against what a
jury's supposed to do I know but a jury
is really supposed to be completely
unbiased and they ask you all these
questions and they go through selection
about the end of the day like there's no
way you'll ever really have a perfect
jury and so I feel like if there were
one of the Gerry 12 people right okay
let's say like the state of New York
hired 12 people who are professionally
trained to be completely unbiased like
and that was their full-time job to be
unbiased and like a political and just
completely stand in the middle of every
issue and like really be able to see
both sides like that could be someone's
job I think like I just feel like that's
such a better way like what do they need
[ __ ] like me and you being on the
jury like I think it would be hilarious
to be on a jury it would get old after
five minutes but like I am least
qualified I would make my mind up in ten
[ __ ] seconds you know well yeah I
mean so maybe you're but maybe if it was
a case that had at you absolutely had no
skin in this game you had never
experienced anything on on your side but
just the concept of training people to
not be biased it's like who's training
those people so could not be biased and
everyone has life experience that will
make the bias in one way or the other
right so if you will limit the amount of
people like you're you're testing every
known in New York you're testing
everyone in New York but for a specific
case yes everyone has life experience
that might make them biased but a lot of
people don't have that not bias you know
they might have eyes about other stuff
but when it comes to this case they
don't have a horse in the race
when you did jury duty like did you get
selected like I got really close like I
went through the whole first day I think
I was down to like the last 40 people
but the case like he privacy by saying
the case was gonna be really long and if
you have a job that you can't do that
for some reason like let him know and at
the time I was like I guess I could like
miss weeks of the toes but then I was
like no like how would I make my income
yeah so then the next day I showed up I
was like I said yesterday that I could
miss four weeks of work but I actually
can't and I was just rambling he was
like goodbye that's so crazy because I
hear people's like stories about Terry
Judy in my story was literally I stayed
in the room for two days and they never
do something that happens yeah happens
have you done jury duty um I've gone
twice and I've completed it once I
remember the time you didn't completely
I was a first day and I was just like
I'm not going back the second day and I
understand that for myself at the time
it's like I had to wake up so early I
was on my spring break from college I
was like I'm not [ __ ] going to jury
duty and it's so far down temperature I
was like I'll go another time and you
know at this time in my life I can do
jury duty when I'm called on even though
I had to push it back as we had Kevin
and master it on the show but I should
have just gone then oh yeah but back
then this seems like big stars yeah and
then I had to miss when I had jury duty
to the last time who did I miss I don't
know maybe see us two key people then
you get charged dude he's so frequently
I'm telling you it's like it's a hunger
now that we're talking about it I know
it's gonna show up in my door like ice
creams were a real thing like I would be
called can we talk a little bit about
the validity of the rumor that if you
don't go to charity you go to prison
like is that true or not um it's you
could go to prison but I don't think
they enacted I don't think they actively
seek but I think they do find you I
think it's also I mean I would pay the
fine whatever it is to not go - I think
it's like $1000 $20.00 and it's not you
don't get fined or you go to prison like
they might find you and then if you're a
real you know evasive character who's
not showing up for jury duty they're
throw your ass in prison yeah I've heard
that like it it didn't give them a
warrant to arrest you they're not gonna
arrest you for that but if there's like
something else and it's just like it's
it adds to your record but I would love
to have a lot professional on the show
to understand you know just what really
happens behind the scenes
mm-hmm well I think it's important that
we all do our civic duty and you know
everybody can be interesting and I feel
like maybe it's a good place to meet
people um network network I could I feel
like that would be oh such a cute
hallmark movie like two people meeting
on the jury but like it would have to be
like not a sad case maybe somebody with
their landlord over bed bug yeah and
would be like so cute so I just feel
like you should go to jury duty because
you never know what's gonna happen and
you could wind up on the Harvey
Weinstein trial and be set for life
because you'll work Nevitt ibly write a
book or you could end up starring a
hallmark movie and then becoming a
princess and see that's anything can
happen thank you anything could happen
anything could happen anything could
[Music]
also I got to thinking a lot about Kim
chose last night I just was like
reminded that we haven't talked about in
a while
January 21st patreon tickets come out
January 22nd general public on sale I'm
just really excited I'm so excited let
me say for people to start getting their
tickets will make the camcos 3 group
everyone will get excited people start
labeling by the way important factoid
there is no bus this year yes there is
no bus this year it's just too much of a
liability like having all these lives
like precious Souls like we're Sully
like driving them up the Poconos in
these mighty roads like the fact that
nobody died is such a miracle we're
gonna never be doing you're gonna leave
it at that
so just like get yourselves here and
figure it out okay rent a car here's the
thing there is no buses here but there
is an episode of the morning toast today
and it is sponsored by honey one of my
better transition you know that honey is
the free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart and you
know how great it feels to save money
but how does it feel to save with honey
it feels [ __ ] awesome I'm not gonna
lie clicking that little button and I
shop online exclusively I find shopping
in stores to be important the most
physically intensive moment like I just
can't do it we're not cavemen you know I
get under broom spread then yours looks
like try and close and you get these
clothes all sweaty no I only shop online
and ever since I downloaded the honey
browser which before they even sponsored
the toast I read about in the toasters
group literally this little bubble comes
up when you're shopping online like hey
want to save money and you press yes and
they just automatically like apply every
coupon in the world and whichever them
works for you and gets you the most
savings saves you the money it's it's
pretty genius they have found over 18
million members and saved over two
billion dollars did you know that honey
supports over 30,000 online stores so if
you shop at Macy's Target Sephora or
Best Buy you can be eligible for savings
um we love honey all their all their
users do it has over a hundred thousand
five star reviews on the google chrome
store
it's a browser extension that you can
install on your browser I use it on
Chrome it's so so right it feels really
good think of it as like a little daily
victory every time you shop it's free to
use and installs in just a few seconds
so get the extension at get honey for
free at join honeycomb slash toast so
the website is join honey dot-com
toast you can get it for free at join
honeycomb slash toast join honey dot-com
slash toast get it for free installs in
just a few seconds
check it out and if you are like me and
you're an investor in online goods and a
collector honey definitely makes makes
that easier on you they support the
collectors collective of America alright
next story nikkietutorials famous
youtuber has come out and revealed that
she is transgender this story is so
crazy because at the end of the day she
was being blackmailed okay the story is
so crazy first so many reasons one she
was blackmailed like what's what evil
pert like I just can't even - I just am
amazed that anyone can keep a secret
these days like mm-hmm
it's so insane like and I never would
have like even thought about it
but then when you just think of like how
many people like her yearbook like like
you don't even like how does anyone keep
something so private these days yeah
good for her yeah um and she's getting
so much love and support from
celebrities who are tweeting at her um
including ariana grande Amber Rose Lena
Dunham yeah really really cool everyone
it always helps when you do something
brave yeah and everyone's talking about
it it has become a really positive thing
but it's it's sad to think that it
started out something so negative that
someone was blackmailing her with it
this information yeah and it sucks that
like she had to come out this way and
like in a way that was forced but um I'm
glad that she didn't come out like in
another way that was like so salacious
and like ruin ^ them all in so it sucks
that it happened this way but like at
least she got her moment you know what I
mean 100% what a crazy story though I
mean shocking like it's just it's just
so crazy yeah it's so crazy I'm really
happy for her virtue of and like the
YouTube community can be so sweet and
like they can be so ugly sometimes of
course but I think in general people
just are very supportive and it's it's
nice to see that yeah and it's just nice
to feel like I'm sure it was really
scary making that video but like I feel
like that was the best it could have
went to lean everyone was just really
happy everyone was really surprised um
and I just think this is so cool like
good for you [ __ ] yeah yeah I love her
stuff michio so premium she did video
with Lady Gaga did you say no but I saw
her conspiracy tutorial as is so good
yeah but Lady Gaga did like
YouTube video with four like house
laboratories and she did it with naked
tutorials
oh that's prestigious yeah and Kesha did
one for capture rose and she did it with
James Charles interesting yeah I find it
interesting like celebrities like
everyone is now starting a makeup line
and flocking to like youtubers to help
promote which is pretty smart
yeah really smart yeah she was like
really cute on James Charles um channel
like she's just really sweet oh that's
sweet yeah yeah I like turnout it was a
good video okay are you ready for our
next story which is just like with has
so many interesting factoids in it in
this one head bag full it's chock full
of interesting factoids let me know see
ya
texted Diplo to see if he was interested
in know string sex SIA revealed she hit
her LSD collaborator Diplo for some
casual sex okay see you did an interview
with GQ GQ for a feat sheet for a
feature on Diplo and so she's dressed I
saw the pictures of Diplo with you so I
new paragraph she's just like it's
dropping bombs much of our relationship
is just being spent trying not to have
sex so that we wouldn't ruin our
business relationship because he's super
duper hot this year I wrote him a text
and said hey listen you're like one of
five people that I'm sexually attracted
to and now that I've decided to be
single for the rest of my life and I
just adopted a son I don't have time for
a relationship if you're interested in
some no-strings sex then hit me up wow
she did feel whether or not yeah she has
a son she adopted a son she didn't
reveal whether they hooked up or not but
like now I'm adding this to my list of
ships that are coming in yeah I actually
own a small port somewhere different
ships and we just got a new one it's
called CEO and Diplo and to me that is
endgame and if it's called biblia yeah
they just like music-wise
personality-wise it's just everything to
me that's so weird because I was really
thinking about SIA this morning and I
was thinking of her personal life
because I was just like having
flashbacks to her performing at the
Kardashian Christmas party and wondering
if like why they became so like close
with SIA maybe it's like she has kids
that are the same age I mean I was just
like really thinking about her personal
life and I just was under the assumption
that she had like a Margot Robbie
marriage like you married someone from
Australia who wasn't nobody in like
they're very much in love
that's not her life however that's not
her life she's single she's single she's
happy being single and now she's a mom
and she just wants to have sex with
Diplo and I feel
though that's a really great place to be
no when I feel as though like I can
really you know yeah she also added that
Diplo is the sweetest thing in the world
but one of the most insecure boys I've
ever met she clarified that he isn't
insecure with his music but more with
himself in his personal relationships
quote he doesn't think he's good enough
at anything he has crazy low self-esteem
it's so interesting because he's one of
the most talented and attractive people
in the world but he doesn't know it I
guess that's what makes him so talented
but she's spilling the tea har har I
love when I'm licked celebrity speak
about other celebrities it's literally
one of my favorite things to like read
about um and this is just like a
friendship that I never even knew
existed but what a good one what a good
one um I mean it makes complete sense
they've collaborated like I'm sure we're
fans of some of the work that they've
done but I've never really put it
together and not in the age since I've
been like obsessed with Diplo which only
really started in the spring but they've
recently released an album together that
like nobody's really talking about LSD I
think it's SIA Diplo and labyrinth like
they and nobody like cared or heard
about it but I didn't know that they
were friends just because of that got it
yeah very cool yeah good stuff I mean I
just I love to see you know celebs
[ __ ] celebs and I hope that they did
in fact [ __ ] or celebs attempting to Fox
labs also love to see it I love the
upfront honesty from CI you know just
really like a woman after what you know
knows what she wants
yeah I would and woman of tastes of
course I mean Diplo i think also an
underrated fact about Diplo that not a
lot of people know is that he's a father
of two yes that's also in the article
and he talks about how like that he
found true love with his kids like they
are just like bringing out the best in
him and that he loves being a dad oh
that's so cute he does really good like
Instagram content with his kids which
means he really loves them a hundred
percent very cute very sweet fifth and
final story a little more like
celebrities dating from [ __ ]
celebrities news it's not business no no
no by the shocking because I did have a
sponsor for a business segment so I mean
you literally contractually have to read
it so please do thrive is an online
membership based market on a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
they have guaranteed savings so enjoy
member only prices up to 25 to 50% off
traditional prices you can also get free
gifts samples and deals every day
the thrive market is a marketplace of
the highest quality healthy and
sustainable products by thousands of
wholesome food home and beauty products
curated just for our members
find everything you need organic and
non-gmo food clean Beauty safe
supplements and non-toxic home plus
ethical meat sustainable seafood clean
wine and more you can easily shop by
70-plus diets and values like keto paleo
gluten-free vegan non-gmo fare treated
certified bpa-free and more get the app
skip the store and the lines it's good
for the planet and it's good for you
orders of forty-nine dollars or more are
shipped free delivered with fast carbon
neutral shipping from their zero waste
warehouse we love we stand a sustainable
brand through with thrive gives their
one-for-one membership matching program
every paid membership sponsors a free
one for a low-income family which is
really really sweet we think that the
toaster is already loved five market but
if you haven't gotten on board go to
thrive market comm slash toast to give
thrive market a try you can choose the
membership model that best fits your
lifestyle they have one month three
months and twelve month options go to
thrive market.com slash toast to get up
to $20 off today we love that you can
choose your membership term so if you
want the 12 month the three month one
month check it out maybe try one month
and you like it go to three and then you
like it go to 12
find the right fit for you you can
easily give it a try just for a shorter
period of time thrive market membership
is risk free you can take the first 30
days to determine if thrive market is
right for you if it's not just cancel
within 30 days and get a full refund so
make sure to go to thrive market calm /
toast and check it out love it sign on
get great stuff so we don't have
business but we do have something else
yes we do have a little bit of celebrity
news that's just gonna take us right
into our bachelor recap you know I love
like a smooth slide like me - what is it
something about revolve no just January
Jones finally confirming that she did
date the bachelors make file and she
confirmed it on a podcast if I'm right
which we just love to see I just can't
stress it enough podcasts making making
the news is all you can really ask for
as a podcast host and we are podcast
hosts who support other podcast host
support other podcasts and I just love
talking about what they're talking about
on their shows which show was she on
armchair expert with Doc Shepherd hmm so
she talks about how in 2017 she was
talking a lot about Nick vile season of
The Bachelor she what did segments for
Jimmy came alive in The Late Late Show
with James Corden just like blasting
Nick vile then apparently Nick caught
wind of her words and decided to hit her
up
social media she said oh she said Nick
slid into my DMS and he's like I'm so
sorry that your perception of me is so
negative I'd love to take you out to
coffee and see if I could change her
mind most like Nick no so slick so
smooth and she said she squealed she
considered turning down the invitation
but she claimed her sister changed her
mind I mean just love a supportive
sister we do it was all good all I did
was grow him about the show she said we
went on a couple of dates she said the
thing that attracted her to bile was
that he was cast as the villain but that
he had a bit of a brain that's all we
were talking about really but I got a
lot of juicy inside scoop yeah I mean I
feel like she found out what we've all
found out in the last few years is that
not only is Nick vile like not the bad
guy he's actually like an intellect he
reminds me a lot of luck chef like chef
is so smart and you just think he's like
a douche but he's actually like a real
like he reads you know yeah literature
but I think that uh while Shep is very
intelligent Nick is very emotionally
intelligent he's also extremely woke Oh
extreme like like he you cannot say
something about women like whoa King of
America he's podcast she recalls getting
woke with Nick yeah totally but it's
called bio files which is such a good
name yeah and I know that this is
confirmation like everyone was talking
about it we all really knew it and you
know what hearing this story it sounds
exactly what it felt like writing like
oh they were flirting on Instagram like
they were giving like they were going
back and forth a little bit so they had
gone on a few dates like I hope this
means that they smooch and that like he
dated Betty Draper like that is so cool
for him I'm so mother my friend now it
makes me wonder what the validity of the
rachel bilson rumors were okay so I
don't think there's much like just that
that one felt different you know um and
now she's with Bill Hader right which I
know we discussed very briefly what are
your thoughts on that relationship
honestly I love it like I I don't
necessarily have a ship for them but I
do have like a small speedboat no it's
like literally I saw them together and I
was just like what like it honestly I
don't ship it what I don't what's not to
ship they're both like so cute and funny
it's just like so so weird to me like
they're just so wrong for each other
oh no I think they're so right for each
other like it just makes sense it's like
they just fit it works no like that's
how I felt about her with Adam Brody
that's how I felt about know that was
this sort of thing I was too good to be
true like that wasn't
that was like a cruise liner you know
and it's like that was it was a
formative a Carnival cruise where like
the crew is drunk and someone's jumping
off the side of a Club Med boat no it
was so perfect and so special and those
were the days
no that's like how Leighton Meester and
Adam Brody are so perfect I'm sorry
Michelle and a little bit unexpected
they still together yes they really
could live such a quiet life right
that's the life like Megan wishes she
could happen yeah it's just too much
Frank Brody and summer Roberts like it
just was okay I wrote down
many notes for the bachelor recap so
should we get into it mm-hmm okay I
literally had to write down people's
names because it was so hard but we
started off with he cancelled the the
rest of the day date after talking to
Hannah oh my god we need to I mean
here's the thing I don't want to go in
on Hannah just in case snitches watching
and I just don't want to trigger her but
like this whole thing is so crazy and
they did leave it very open-ended and
then watching the preview for the rest
of the season it's like you think she
comes back at the finale like where he
gets a piece of information he says he's
gonna throw up yeah and I feel like that
piece of information might have been
that the woman he's about to propose to
like maybe has a boyfriend or something
like that like information that makes it
so that he should not propose to this
woman or maybe she had like things that
she did that made it clear that she
doesn't love him maybe because
production has to tell him then I think
maybe they take some time off and he
gets back together with Hannah I don't
know if that's my ultimate prediction
but that's one route and last night's
ending with Hannah left it open tonight
yeah but I just was really surprised
that not more of the women were like
vocal about how incredibly unfair it was
like I mean natasha natashas the voice
of a generation
she said Hannah B has been here every
day that I've seen you she's the only
one outraged and the only one having a
normal reaction and I get that like all
these women are trying to win Peter's
heart but like why would Peter want a
girl who just stands around and waits
like two like hey does anyone have any
uh like self-confidence like it was just
like every me they take your time no
[ __ ] I put my life on hold because I
think you're really cute I want to date
you and right here come on to being with
another girl like what's up what's
roblem no it was like I was so shocked
that she was only one having a normal
reaction yeah no I loved her reaction
she said everything that like we at home
were thinking Peter really respected her
for what she said she really stood out
in the bunch for me oh and that was just
after finding out that I have a mutual
friend with Natasha right so then I
automatically respect know I have no
choice but to stand at this
um and she wasn't she was saying when he
was like I you know it's hard to get
over someone she was like yeah it's also
hard to get over someone when you're
seeing them all the time like she needs
to stop coming around everyday I've seen
you she's been here right so I'm so glad
that was put to bed but it didn't feel
like completely put about his own I know
of course not it was very open-ended she
has to go back to dance with the Stars
but um she eventually like stops Dancing
with the Stars she does then we went on
to the rest of the group date where
McKenna um made us cringe with her
dancing and forcing Peter to dance oh I
must oh oh oh in the room and then he
like put her up like I'll find a shot oh
my god with your legs like up in the air
like why didn't I didn't see more
screenshots of that on Twitter but I saw
so many oh my god I thought her legs on
the air was like one of the most
inappropriate thing I've ever seen you
know what I did in um I didn't pick my
head up for the part where she was
dancing but I did look at her Instagram
and she already made her bio cringy mind
answer it's just like the thirst knows
no bounds in like wheat that was so
clear at their evolved event no okay her
thirst knows no bounds she's just she's
giving me vibes of a girl who was not
there for the right reasons like saw
Cassie ran up on TV and was like that
could be me no not only that I'm out
she's all over tick-tock like posting my
bachelor stuff I saw one of her videos
on my home page cos she might be like
the thirstiest contestant and the one
who even though maybe likes Peter is
really there for the wrong reasons and
nowadays the wrong reasons
means like yeah maybe you're interested
in not even that it's like you don't
even you don't want to win you want to
be an influencer you want to go to
paradise you want to do or evolve like
that's max I wanna maybe get far enough
where you're relevant and I feel like
for a lot of girls who go on The
Bachelor like they're there for love and
the experience and then that comes with
it and they know that that's siting and
they know that that's waiting for them
and they don't not want it but that's
not really like the number one reason
like a lot of them really are like
wanting to fall in love and I don't
think that's naive of us to think no or
they they know that they watch the show
they know the lead they like that guy or
girl
um I think everyone knows that there are
perks that come along with it and
they're excited about that but for
McKenna it feels for me that he is she's
strictly there on a business trip like
she expends yep her flight and her
wardrobe she flew business class it's a
tax write-off for her yeah
the group date ended with McKenna not
getting the group rose even though she
was like so sure that she was gonna get
it
give it to that girl Sydney who's from
Alabama and who says she's not a typical
southern girl and she is so sweet and
pretty and like she worried you fell
like stunning people she was like
literally nowhere to be found in the
first episode like I never saw her in my
life but she really rose to the top of
this origin sending I think she's gonna
go places like literally location-wise
she's gonna travel with them and she's
gonna go far and then we saw the
unraveling of Kelsey it first started
with her coming for McKenna because we
kind of spoke to Peter when I guess
Kelsey like had the intention of
speaking to Peter um and she was just
totally wrong in Makena I handled it
very similar to Hannah and like really
just like being like okay I want that
for no I thought she got stuck in the
mud a little bit there should mean know
how to get out of it and she was like
she was trying it was a weird
conversation he was trying to flip it
back but um she got she got stuck it was
like sticking that's where we see
Kelsey's start to unravel unravel spiral
outward okay I have something I know
controversial to say what happens is
Hanna and accidentally takes the bottle
of Dom Perignon that she that Kelsey to
Des Moines it's like very local to Des
Moines yeah it's very specific it's an
aged champagne we do see that there was
another bottle of champagne set up on
the other gazebo Prosecco which by the
way was 100% orchestrated by producers
like it was just - - there was like it
was just such an easy explanation for
this mix-up you know what I mean yeah
but I feel like having a bottle of
champagne set up at the bachelor mansion
like he's just another thing around it
that made it seem like it was homemade
like it literally had candles champagne
and a glass which is all over the
mansion right but I don't think
producers like setup - so that someone
would take hers I think like someone
might have wanted like a sweet setup
like there's only so many ideas of
things romantically right - right um and
that's when Kelsey really lost her mind
when she heard the champagne pop and
just couldn't contain her emotions and
was running around gotcha ranch and
having people hug her and like locking
herself in the bathroom and saying knows
that she don't wanna talk to Peter even
though like she was finally getting her
opportunity and she was squandering it I
just want to say that one you know Dom
hang on Dom Perignon is very expensive
oh my god totally from a financial
standpoint she was at a loss 1,000% I
have about two bottles of Dom Perignon
for like my college graduation that I
still haven't opened and - even though
like she's a little nuts Patchett um I
like her other she's
stunning but she was wrong like I
couldn't get on board and she was wrong
in that instance but like over the whole
episode like I love an emotional Queen
I love someone who's gonna stand up to
Hannah Anna and then Hannah Anstead
gonna say she's bullied like that is so
[ __ ] crazy to me but by the way why I
don't understand why like everyone in
the house thinks Hannah and and to me
there has to be something up with Hannah
and because now this is the second time
someone's coming for her but like she
literally seems so nice what is the
problem if there's just something it's
just like a gut feeling but then it's
making me think that she wins because it
looks like she's being protected like
everyone is coming for her but we have
no reason to understand why I don't
think she was I mean when you get the
first impression rose like there's a
target on your back she's so cute she's
so confident she doesn't question
herself and like that is there's
definitely like some jealousy in the mix
but I do also think she's a little too
perfect I think a lot of the girls just
pick up on maybe some like nefarious
vibes I just feel like that's too vague
for me like what did she do it's just a
feeling sometimes okay but that's not
fair to like come at someone for a
feeling I know no I'm coming at you from
my financial loss of my Dom pérignon
when I think oh but she didn't know okay
but like when you when you get in a
ferry vibe from someone and then they
steal your own and then they say they
didn't know it makes you question
whether or not they knew again but then
that you've literally sound so [ __ ]
paranoid ever since listen I would not
because because it's very possible that
Hannah's actually just a nice girl and
she didn't know about the champagne sure
but also the girl who shows up in a
wedding dress is always [ __ ] crazy oh
by the way that always guy see I
couldn't believe that she made the top
two with that that was the loser rias
thing ever so loser II and like Janice
Dickinson like we expect better for me
you know totally it was so thirsty so
obviously I really did not like that um
um no but I want to say like even though
if I were Kelsey I would never have
found myself in this situation nor would
I have had with it this way like I don't
know I just
I'd like there's something like real and
likable and funny about her sorry and
the [ __ ] champagne on her face like
was just hilarious and she handled it so
well
Oh 1,000% and she got like if she got
memed she's getting the proper bachelor
treatment I thought like they made it
seem like she was gonna have like an
emotional breakdown and to me she was
like a little nuts with that
conversation with Hannah Hannah but she
wasn't that crazy maybe it gets worse I
don't know but Hannah anson itching is
so [ __ ] looser he like to me and
saying she was bullied like I'm sorry
you're not a real housewife had a
reunion
you haven't been bullied just because
you've been called out based on how
someone feel like bullying is like a
system it's such a serious thing and
like I'm sorry kind of an you're not the
victim ugly no I just hate he was a
bully and to me like whenever someone
goes in stitches to The Bachelor about
right like they're automatically in the
wrong and I was on Hanna side until that
but that was just an incredibly lame
thing to do totally and I feel like
Peter was really about to send Kelsey
home cuz he was like I will not have
police here and I don't know what she
said but she changed his mind and he
likes how I am yeah but honestly like
it's hard to read Peter because he makes
out with everyone and you would think
that he's like in love with McKenna
putting her up on the thing but to me
the only person I ever felt real emotion
from him was with Madison I think like
she's definitely top - yeah
giving her that thing and she was just
like giggling they weren't even talking
they were just like putting their faces
in front of me it really does seem like
he loves everyone right so maybe she
loved no one or does he actually love
everyone agreed um then we get to the
revolve group date which is just at
first I was like this is so [ __ ]
loser II like I could die but then the
more he thought about it I actually
thought it was pretty brilliant um
revolves behalf it was great marketing
those girls are gonna work for revolve
anyway it's just like them getting in
the door I think it was pretty pretty
genius no it was really genius and for
me like Peter didn't handle it the way
that I would have if I were the bachelor
which is like to use it as like test
material anyone who got too excited or
like knew too much and is really here to
be like revolves next-hop influencer
okay as the snatcher said needs to go
home and I think whoever won the
competition I'd be like thank you for
showing your true colors like it is
there's the door yeah I'm in Kenan
Hanahan like if he really is looking for
what wife what's important to note is
professionally Hannah Anna's a model
mm-hmm
so I didn't really think that her
winning was so thirsty like she's a
model if she didn't win like she's not
very good at her job
ya know it just like it's the excitement
over of all that I just felt like I told
you everything and be like having like a
fabfitfun box yeah and whoever can tell
it the best like goes home but I think
by the way you're in The Bachelor house
you get $20,000 worth of revolve clothes
like thank you I'm going on group dates
Rose ceremonies like it's actually
necessity is the mother you know what I
mean no but I also found like I was
really disappointed in a lot of the
girls style like 10 like Hannah and is
so cute has great style and then like
chose like to pretty label skirt was
terrible but I would have had like a
buzzer on that hat that conductor hat
whoever picked it up goes home you're
picking up that hat
you want to be an influencer that's a
second only wear that hat when I'm like
interested in influencing someone well I
think that the and this is gonna sound
so mean the episode came to an end with
Victoria getting the group-date Rose
because she opened up about our
insecurities and like is it so terrible
of me to think that like I just didn't
believe anywhere that was coming out of
her mouth like girls like girls like her
are just not insecure I can't explain it
I just thought like I think she'd seen
many one too many episodes of The
Bachelor and so like okay let me open up
my insecurities overcome that insecurity
and then I'll win like it's a formula
and to me she looked like she was just
following a formula you don't if you're
insecure you don't get out of a limo and
tell the bachelor that your pussy's wet
like you just seem like something you
would do I just I wasn't believing a
single word coming out of her mouth and
I know that's so mean because she was
being voted it all together like that
I'm gonna say she's not in the formula
was just so pen lingerie in a trench
coat yeah it's bright oh yeah so you the
most insecure girl but you're the only
one wearing lingerie like I'm sorry I
just the whole thing was so calculated
like she had seen one too many episodes
of The Bachelor about overcoming your
fears like your figure of heights and
you do it and you get the Rose because
you cried like it's just it was too
perfect I totally agree oh my god my
thoughts on that period I'm done with
any contestant who repeatedly says I'm
done I can't like walking away saying
I'm going home like you now you need to
leave I'm done with you I think if you
threatened to go home it should be a
rule that you have to be have a car
waiting for you outside
like you have to go home yeah I totally
agree
okay well that's our week on The
Bachelor if you're looking for something
more in depth check out the Snatcher
there's a brand new episode going in on
the girls Margo's very very team Hannah
so you'll get a different perspective
and she's very team Hannah and also so
check it out if you're looking for
difference of opinions when you're gonna
bring out Kristen Dodie which I'm so
[ __ ] excited about I have
literally two hours worth of stuff to
talk to her about so we're gonna do that
our segment with Kristen do day is
brought to you by classpass one thing
that we love about classpass is that
it's an all-access membership to over
30,000 of the best gyms and fitness
studios all over the world you can go
where you want when you want how you
want class classes everything you need
to be need to make working out fun you
can try new workouts with studios
without the commitment of going to a
single gym or overpaying for drop ins
they have Yoga strength training spin
bar even boxing class press gives you a
variety and the accountability
you need to attend class just like Teddy
Mellencamp they've got something for
everyone near your work near house class
passes everywhere I've been my friends
used to talk about class pass so many
years ago and I was like damn that
sounds some interesting and now it's
like taking over the world everyone has
it it's kind of genius it's really um
it's cheap it makes sense financially
it's just really smart on the monthly
memberships that start at just fifteen
dollars you can cancel anytime
mix it up and find the perfect studios
and classes just for you get your first
month free at class past comm slash new
years we did the read for class class a
little while ago and everyone was like
begging for the code again so here it is
ready class pass dot-com / new years
that's class plus class past comm / new
years for your first month entirely free
make sure to check out check out class
past comm / new years give us a couple
minutes we're gonna take a quick break
and be back with Kris and Dodi if you
have any questions for her feel free to
drop them on the YouTube livestream we
are so excited to have her here we will
be right back you want more about your
content head over to the snatchler good
stuff see you soon
okay we are back and I'm so excited our
first guest in our brand-new studio
Chris and Jody is here and it couldn't
be more topical because we spoke about
you so much I speak as Lane I want to
let you know like I'm your biggest
champion and I really felt like everyone
was being so hard on you in the first
episode in a borderline hypocritical so
I'm like here to blow smoke up your life
I'm here to blow smoke up your ass and
I'm so glad that you're here because I'm
like literally your number one champion
and we got to hang out this season I
literally saw myself in the background
at the wedding on the promo and I was
like so excited cuz I'm in on TV we got
to hang out at the wedding which we'll
talk about which was so much fun we just
started the new season of Vanderpump
rules thank you for being here you're in
town doing watch happens live yeah so
you so excited I'm so stoked you love
doing that it's really fun right it goes
by so fast yeah it's crazy to like cut
the fat and not write shut up SE Cupp oh
she's a big house wit and Bravo fan
that's fun
she's real intellect I've been I've been
on with her before and yes she was
really kind so I'm like I feel like she
likes you yeah she's nice yeah
okay so first episode of Vanderpump
rules came back we saw a little bit of
an eruption at the housewarming party
before we talk about that coming you
just talk about how did anyone else
realize before Stassi called it out on
the show that all the new houses look
the same oh yeah of course
okay it's so funny and weird it might be
the same except for mine but yeah he was
in college a mine was built in 1939 not
2018 it's really cute are you fully
moved in oh yeah and the number one
question we got for you was carter
living with you no oh good that's great
are you guys together at all I'm so
proud of you that is so great single and
ready to mingle
yeah do you want to jump back into a
relationship I mean I'm kind of hanging
out with someone right now but I don't
think I need a boyfriend I don't think
you do think I just need to like pump
the brakes and chill yeah at least until
my book comes out I can't keep writing
new chapters about the new people and
say life right like personal personal
anecdotes um Carter is gonna be not
gonna be on the show anymore right he
was really only on because of you he'll
be on this whole season but probably not
moving forward
I don't see why he would be you know
yeah I wouldn't be that his favorite
thing in the entire world either
really yeah he gets dragged a little bit
yeah say like his piece we only hear
what people think about him so it's hard
to full-time cast me yeah it was hard to
get to know him well I really like I was
list I was watching everyone fight with
you and what really turned what really
turned to me is when you said to Lala
she was you were like if I ever went up
to Randall and was like talking about
your relationship and like getting about
like you would literally kill me she
would have my head on a platter and yeah
and then it's just like I I felt like
really on your side then I'm like that's
so true like we're all adults here like
why is everyone getting about it and I
like you asked everyone to get involved
it's like everyone is I took it upon
themselves to put themselves in the
middle of your relationship right and I
felt like that couldn't remember yeah
it's it's hard for you you're obviously
we live in these moments that fight was
what a year ago yeah like in the summer
right and and so now you're not only be
living it but people are like coming for
you on Twitter and you've kind of like
taken on this role of like crazy Kristen
for the last few years but every time I
see you in speech you you're like the
most stable person I've ever met and
like you're actually really smart is it
hard for you to like go back to that
like dark place yeah I feel like crazy
Kristen kind of like died a little while
ago but I mean we're all crazy right a
little bit yeah I mean so if you're
gonna come at me or come after someone
especially someone that I love so
although Carter and I are like
definitely not together we weren't even
together over the summer it was still
really complicated and I was in the
middle of like buying this house and
like moving my whole life and doing
everything by myself and it was
terrifying yeah and so I'm always gonna
protect him first and foremost because
he didn't he started filming the show
because of me like he was doing me a
solid didn't ask for it yeah exactly
yeah I get why you feel protective of
him yeah so this summer cuz we were
talking about like what we would have
done if we were friends in your
situation or in your situation so when
you were moving the summer and we saw
that conversation when had you guys
broken up like how how long in February
so in the summer it was like four button
mm-hmm okay that's fair for a breakup I
know we still live together I bought my
house in April I didn't move till June
and just six and breakups are so
difficult like we live is yeah we had
the apartment together and I did ask him
to move out but you know it took time
and at that point I'm just like whatever
right if we live together for four
months than we do and there were times
that we were still getting along and we
were still sleeping together and then
there were times we wanted nothing to do
with EJ
and we just yeah it definitely we
dragged it out a lot but it also had an
ending date when you moved out like that
ready that clean slate yeah so we got so
many questions obviously on the status
of your relationship with Carter but
also on your status of a relationship
with a lot of the girls and we were just
talking earlier about how a bunch of the
girls are into Park City and scheana and
Ariana were not invited and they're
complaining about it on Twitter and we
were guessing whether you were invited
and you had to work cuz you're on watch
admins live tonight that's yeah that's
why I've just been so busy sorry did you
know about the trip I found out last
night on Instagram Chuck and you what is
the trip for I'm guessing it's for
Katie's birthday maybe Katie and
Brittany's birthday what is the catch
from Park City Rob The Witches of WeHo
the wine because not only did you guys
give yourselves that name but you
started a company yes so the wines still
going strong at least the first two
potions you loved it I think it's the
best thing ever
yeah so yeah we still have potion number
two and push number one selling once
you'll see a lot of this on the season
okay who within the witches wants
nothing to do with the wine and and who
wants to continue it on so right now
we're definitely still selling it as far
as like a third potion
you know it'll I don't know I think once
we get to that bridge we'll cross it but
there's a possibility that it could be
me with someone totally different
Wow so what's the status of the
friendship between you Katie and it
doesn't sound good
no yeah um it's honestly as of late it's
a little bit different with both I don't
I don't like to put Katie and Stassi in
one box and say like they're one person
with one brain Katie's a little more
receptive to having conversations with
me like about the wine or about work or
what-have-you but when we see each other
in passing like in our Vanderpump rules
premiere party they were cool and
cordial and kind enough but that's kind
of it I haven't really talked to see
something happen or I'm gonna find out
with you guys my god
I am watching with all of the viewers
and I'm just waiting to see what they
say when I'm not with them on camera cuz
I'm like what did I do
yeah so crazy you know Vanderpump rules
is really one of the
shows where the show and real life like
it's the same like oh yeah I still just
meet up to film like you're hanging out
living in the same apartment building
living around the block from each other
so it's just so crazy to hear you talk
about these friendships the same way off
camera and on camera oh yeah absolutely
that's just so shocking yeah we're not
on we're not a scripted show no not at
all but you know that firsthand yeah and
sometimes people like even the
housewives it's not scripted but they
won't see each other like the situations
aren't orchestrated then then stuff
happens once you get them all in the
room together but you guys are already
in that room together so just putting up
cameras and it's so strange because you
guys have this like really deep history
and now we're bringing on new cast
members and Jax has been very vocal
about the fact that he despises them
yeah and he has no no room for them but
what are your thoughts on Dana and
everyone I mean I think it's always
helpful to bring in like some fresh
blood and just didn't see how it works
out if they're already working at Sur
anyway like why not obviously it's you
know Sheena's already hooked up with new
guys I really like Dana I really like
Brett I love max I don't know Brett like
all that well but he's always really
great in passing and I think Dana was in
like awesome addition I think so too is
that cool yeah it's always like a sticky
like transition but I feel like it'll be
it'll be good for the show yeah I just
think if people are gonna like really
hate on them it's just because you're
jealous of course don't take my screen
time away I don't care about new people
totally I just have this thing in
stassi's kind of the same way like keep
everyone out of my bubble this is my
Bible I like my little bubble too but
every friend you've ever had as was once
a stranger so just like give him a shot
like what if you fall in love with these
people yeah you know so everyone's kind
of progressing you see everyone buying a
house and starting businesses start a
book and now you're writing a book yes
and when is it come out June 2nd 2020
June 2nd 2020 billable for pre-order on
Amazon right now plug it girl on Amazon
check it out
tell me about the process of writing a
book did was it hard like it's very
daunting um it's a lot of work it's a
lot of sleepless nights but so I don't
have a ghostwriter as we were talking
about I started my podcast I really
commend did Kristen because I follow you
on twitter I'll be back
and I saw that you like got into it with
a Jezebel reporter and Jezebel is
website if you haven't heard a bit like
you truly don't need to its website it's
what's me website for women but I find
that they're always like tearing women
down and they were like making fun of
Kristen and her book and saying that
Kristen doesn't own a ghostwriter is and
it was just so mean and like resident
could have easily let it go but like
Kristen came for the reporter and
sometimes these reporters think they
brought crazy Kris reporter seeing that
they can just say stuff and have no like
base or foundation for it and you just
came through and I really appreciated
that so it's commend you on your effort
and if your book is anything like that
it really much looking for I'm looking
forward to reading yes thanks and it is
co-written and you ran straight on the
cover yeah absolutely Michelle Alexander
wrote How to Lose Guy in ten days
amongst a few other books she's a really
good friend of mine actually met through
Tom Schwartz and a couple of our other
like New York friends that are in the
music industry and she and I became
friends probably I don't know six seven
years ago and when I had this idea for
this book I just went straight to her
because she knows exactly what she's
doing and I sort of gave her the layout
and I gave her maybe like six seven
pages of what I've already written and
she had a lot of really great ideas and
because she's done it she was really
helpful with the structure and the
storytelling of it using all of my
stories and my ideas so the book
basically it's like all of my entire
dating history starting from my first
kiss to where I'm at now and all the
stuff you've seen on Vanderpump rules
everything you don't know about on
Vanderpump rules
it's very tongue-in-cheek it's very
comedic very facetious and it's just
saying like we're here to take the C
word back like guys want to call us
crazy so we're gonna own our crazy but
we're gonna tell you why it's all your
method with other C word I'm like well
that sounds really good sounds like my
perfect kind of book I was so excited
I'm just also looking for the T is it is
it piping hot tea is away filled with
team I figured that it would be I want
to take some questions from Instagram we
I've never had so many questions
important for someone and this isn't a
question just a statement from Claire
Cooney please thank her for her years of
service so thank you for your service um
next question
I'm from Corrine stints are you loving
your new house have you decorated it yet
I do love my new house when I first
bought my house I was absolute like just
full panic mode I called my mom like
days after first moving in and I was
like can I give it back right is there
like a refund
like returning refund is terrifying what
do you fill it all up with because I
hate I like redid my floors I knocked
down a wall like all these things I'm
like which order do I go in and like I
have to like call a plumber I don't have
a landlord anymore what the hell do I do
having a landlord like can't relate but
also but which order do you go in do
you'd start with your florist you start
with knocking down the wall and then you
do the floors and then I redid the
kitchen I still have so much to do I
mean my backyard was like a giant pile
of dirt and I'm like I need landscaping
I do astroturf doing there full-time
yeah oh yeah I moved it in June so
that's not so fun just me and my -
sounds like a dream
I'm no rat Emily calendar are you going
to stassi's wedding or do you not know
yet because it sounds like you guys are
on the fritz I haven't gotten to save
the date yet she's other people get save
the dates I don't know because they're
all bridesmaids oh right um
and what about Lala and her wedding are
you a bridesmaid in her wedding I'm not
a bridesmaid but are you invited yeah
okay that's great that's good it sounds
so but oh let's do to attract some
Ernie's wedding because I was there
really really beautiful beautiful and I
was really shocked because I've never
been to a televised wedding before um
and I really felt like the crew did a
great job of not interfering and like
owning the moment um and my favorite
part of the wedding which I'm just about
to be like so shady
I think part of the wedding was
Brittany's dad he's so precious and he
made a prayer before it like they put
down the food and he made a prayer
before everyone ate and you know Lisa's
mom had just passed away and she didn't
officiate the wedding
and he said such a nice prayer and then
was like and let's also just keep ELISA
in our thoughts and it was so sweet I
looked over at Lisa and she looked like
outraged about it and I was like oh my
god what is this lady doing and I found
out later that Brittany's dad the
precious man that he is cleared it with
Lisa so she knew that it was going to be
said and she still acted like all
surprised and mad yeah cries you know
it's I mean Lisa it's gonna do at least
once to do it's her show and there was a
period of time with Lisa it was really
hard on you yeah this summer she was
she's lightened up so much okay I just I
think between everything that happened
with the housewives and her and then all
of the trauma that she's had with her
family of the last year I just think is
really like shifted her attitude a lot
so and then she saw me going through a
lot this summer with the girls with
Carter I had some family stuff going on
and she was just really kind
me it's so out here I'm not gonna hold
my breath but right now I'm like really
enjoying me that was always really
bothersome the way that she treated you
and like gave everyone else so many
chances and it never sad you just took
the words out of my grant yeah nothing
you ever wanted to work back it's sir
but it's like just seeing someone gets
so many second chances and then you
losing out on like moments and times
with your friends because you didn't
work out sir like it all just oh really
I told someone to second dick like it's
just the punishment wasn't where's the
crime no you know but thank you for
saying yeah because I come online and I
say it ever and if I ever meet someone
named Diana I just like second day it
was so real so really and I'm like with
a cigarette in your hand like it was
jumping crazy Kristen yeah okay from akh
okay why Jackie um what are you working
on now after the book you have James May
what's new and next for Kristen still
working on James May always working on
James May I'm working on right now like
spring collections done summer
collections almost done already working
on fall for next year so that's always
gonna be my baby the book
we're finally completely finished with
it which is awesome but we're still in
the process of like you know choosing
the illustrations and the format and the
fonts and like all of like the fun stuff
with our publishing that have you shot
the cover yet yeah we did we should I
killer sickening on it love the hair
I have a question about James May and
I'm sure you get this question a lot but
there was a period in your life where
you like you were dating James they need
a change I already correlated and I long
after my niece and nephew never name
anything after he [ __ ] on the bottom of
my shoes Jake kids wants to know what
are your thoughts on everyone reuniting
and apologizing and reconciling with
James I think that they're absolutely
insane but you know good for that I mean
especially Jax being like I'm so proud
of him I'm so proud of him and like just
give it a year you know I mean if he
really is sober and doing better with
his life than like good for him I'm not
gonna you know drag him anymore but yeah
I'm just like keep a hundred feet
distance yeah not holding mm-hmm Sam
Valentino what is one scene that you
wish never aired
like in all your Vanderpump history
I mean obviously the [ __ ] slap heard
around the world that's the hardest
thing for me to I hate like the memes
and everything of that yeah oh god that
is like that's the worst thing ever
that's but also just like really wasted
moments when you can't understand a word
coming out of my mouth perhaps falling
over a table once or twice yeah but just
as a viewer I want to let you know like
I don't regret it like so much I loved
it so much thank you I have the most
random question for you because I'm
remembering a few seasons ago you're
friends with Jade from The Bachelor yeah
correct
and she just won the draftkings lot I
saw I haven't mean I haven't I know I
haven't asked her about it but I did say
I think it's [ __ ] that she's being
investigated like if she was on The
Bachelor like nobody would have cared ya
know and like what she's being
investigated for like she did the
maximum number of entries so did her
husband like that seems like what any
couple who does draftkings would do I
think they're gonna be fine I think
they're I hope so like that's so
exciting for her April Gor Zell what do
you think of Sheena's role on Vanderpump
rules now it does seem like she's
starting to phase out like she's not
really in your group anymore her
storyline is very much with the new
people she's in a weird I like that I
love scheana the season from like I mean
I love scheana anyway but like scheana
on the show I'm just like let's scheana
live like I think this is the first time
she's just sort of owning everything
that she is like she's especially the
episode that airs tonight like it she
just cracks me up because she's no
longer being that sort of wishy-washy
flip-floppy I really want to be in this
group but everyone like these people
she's just like this is who I am
oh good she's so many seasons like not
being herself and an attempt to get
people to like her and yeah the opposite
effect so I'm glad that she's finally
like comfortable in her own skin and and
one just because her scenes crack me up
like she is she's hilarious
um see see a DB how do you become a
better traveler I'm a pretty decent
traveler
I don't Europe is like a whole nother
story I'm totally terrified of Europe
and that was the first the whole
Copenhagen thing was the first time I
ever experienced jetlag in my life and I
think it was like a combination of that
and like getting hammered and like not
understanding sleep schedules and being
on a trip with a bunch of girls that
tend to fight it's a lot
I understand that um we got a really
good question for you which I never
thought about but when you think of like
who I know you're seeing someone but
like if you ever were to date like I and
I'm single yeah if you ever did fun
dating
if you ever were to date like in the
Bravo circle would you ever date Shep no
no absolutely not did you hear Britney
in Jackson watch happens I'd say that he
was the worst wedding yeah he was the
worst I literally was with him the whole
time like does that mean yes
take it down we're accessory to worse
hold all this like in the scene that I'm
in I'm like standing next to chef like
I'm just it's so embarrassing for me I'm
leaving take him down
Wheaton also so hammered like he was
absolutely the most hammered out about
whoa is he on a few scenes I he was
miked at one point oh yeah we went with
scheana right like something goes um
probably with all of us I mean there was
one night that yeah that she and I like
we were like we want to go hit the town
we want to go out let's go like toward
where the hotel where like the guests
you say I totally makes me now I was
there yeah and then and we were like oh
yeah
and Shep was like walking into traffic
and just being drunk then all of a
sudden one of our producers is behind us
with his iPhone he's like I'm not
missing a damn thing where are you guys
going what does have no ma am i right no
okay wait also at Bravo con there were
rumors that you and Craig Conover were
an item
prewar yes or maybe no you haven't no he
had a girl with him mmm I'm not saying I
wasn't gonna try
he's so many he had a girl with who in
the Bravo sphere would you be interested
in if anyone I would say if anyone at
all I would probably be Craig okay
he's so cute yeah he's like a really
really really good friend of mine but
good yes there's a lot of crossover on
southern charm in Vanderpump rules like
everyone seems to know each other yeah
we do I wish they would like let us
actually crossover yeah that would be
great like a girl let's do it was summer
house and I Sasha that was fun um he was
on a trailer for some warehouse yeah I
show that too so I was like okay now
where's our southern charm banter
pumpkin it's like they're just
leveraging all these shows to make
summer house with good and it's never
gonna be good
they keep trying be good yeah okay so
everyone needs to preorder your book on
Amazon yes
follow Kristin on Instagram for all the
updates on James May on her book
honestly you seem like you're a really
great place you know enjoy Twitter I'm
going to wear my saltiness we had a
really long conversation about the show
and I just like ah now I'm gonna watch
the rest of the season with different
eyes and I love having guests come on
the show and make me feel that way
because I've been a champion of Christie
justice for Kristin just taste justice
for that's what I'm saying I think I cry
a lot this season though ever but now
I'm on the other side yeah I love you
thank you for stopping hello Kristin
Doty on Instagram kr ist en dou T E
thank you for listening to the morning
chess and Lenny Morning Show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so watching us
on YouTube please feel free to subscribe
leave a five-star review about like how
beautiful setting that's where we are on
the podcast app thank you so much have a
great day we will see you tomorrow